let's apply the work-energy theorem
principle to the motion of a block
sliding down an inclined plane and
here's an inclined plane at an angle
theta and let's choose a coordinate
system we'll choose x equals 0 up here I
had here and here is our coordinate
function and suppose that the object
starts at X I that it ends at X final if
we want to calculate the work-energy
then what we're going to learn is that
there this theorem is two different
sides calculating the change in kinetic
energy is simply a description this is
1/2 M V final squared minus 1/2 V
initial squared that's a property
parameters of the system at the initial
state the speed the or the velocities
speed which is connect speed squared and
the same property the final in the final
state now over here we have two types of
forces acting on the subject so here we
need a free body force diagram first and
this side is where the physics are you
lie and so we want to draw our force
diagram so if we have our block we have
the friction force we have the normal
force we have mg the call plane is
inclined theta that's also the angle
theta if we chose I had J hat unit
vectors I just want to repeat that on my
Freebody diagram now we can think of
this integral as just one dimensional
motion in the X direction and so we have
two different forces that we have to
calculate the friction force is in the
minus X direction so we're integrating
minus the friction force with respect to
displacement from X initial to X final
and what about the gravity
a tional force well the gravitational
force has a component mg sine-theta in
the x-direction so when we integrate
that x component we have now plus
because it's in the same direction
remember we're displacing a little bit
DX down the inclined plane so we're
going from X initial X final of mg sine
theta which is a constant DX and so when
you're applying the work energy theorem
you need to integrate your forces and
actually calculate the work now again if
you looked in the J hat direction and we
applied Newton's second law and minus mg
cosine theta is zero and our rule for
friction is its new K times N or mu K mg
cosine theta then what we have is in
both instances we have a constant force
so it's just force times displacement so
we have minus mu K mg cosine theta times
the displacement which is X initial X
final over here we have mg sine theta
times X final minus X initial and now
we've calculated separately both sides
of our work kinetic energy principle as
in all our physical laws the equal sign
means the work is equal to the change in
kinetic energy I'll emphasize that by
now placing the equal sign because of
our physical law and so equaling
one-half M V final squared minus V
initial squared and now I have a
relationship between the parameters of
the initial state which I'm calling X
initial and V initial and the parameters
that describe the final state X final V
final and depending on which set of
these parameters are given I can
conceivably solve for the other ones one
thing I do want to point out when we do
this example is we've described work as
a dot product from A to B take the
friction force well in this instant if
we wrote this out explicitly it would be
minus FK I
dot DX I had from the initial to the
final I had done I had is one and so you
see we recover from X initial 2x final
of FK DX and that was the first piece
the second piece the gravitational force
dotted into DS from X initial 2x final
well if you wrote down the gravitational
force mg as a I hat component and a
negative mg cosine theta J hat component
then when we take the dot product again
where our D s here we'll write d s as DX
I had then when u dot product mg dot d s
mg dot d s we have I hat dot I hat which
is 1 but J hat dot I hat they're
perpendicular so that's 0
so the only piece that survives in the
scalar product M G dot d s is these two
pieces and so we get the integral from X
initial 2x final of mg sine theta times
D X and that's precisely our second
piece here so here's the simple
application of the work-energy theorem